i'm sitting here with my daughter and
we're sewing some masks
so i thought we'd take this opportunity
to maybe help some people
make their own masks at home actress
hilary burton morgan
knows the extent of her influence
there's so many people putting their
life on the line to take care of us
and so if we're sitting around let's
just make them some masks
so she masked up when we sat down with
her at oblong books in upstate new york
i think if i sat here without a mask
and on my social media it's masked mask
mask mask i would be a hypocrite i try
not to ask anyone to do something i'm
not willing to do
and i have to walk the walk you know
these days burton and her husband
jeffrey dean morgan
walk the walk in dutchess county jeffrey
and hillary can you give us a tour
around the farm
that's where they say they found comfort
that's hard to come by
do you know what drew you to this place
you and jeff
yeah it was our childhood homes were
destroyed
the small towns disappeared the mom and
pop shops disappeared everything got
replaced by big massive chains
so when we found this community that was
all mom and pop shops
it was so important to us that we
preserved it
and we honored it in a way that other
people maybe saw the value in it
one of those shops is samuels a candy
store opened
more than 25 years ago when owner ira
guttner passed away suddenly in 2014
it was in danger of closing there was a
huge amount of panic especially for my
husband because he was out of the
country
and he was adamant he's like hillary you
tell john do not close
do not close it can still overwhelm me
it was just really kind
john traver who's worked at samuel since
he was a teenager
was grieving and uncertain about the
business's future
i had so much going on worried about
paying for the easter candy that wasn't
paid for and a whole bunch of other
bills to have this powerful person
who relatively recently entered our our
life come in and say we're going to
we're going to protect this yeah don't
worry everything's okay it was really
special
burton and morgan put together a group
that included their friends
actor paul rudd and wife julie to buy
samuels
once the deal was finalized burton got
to work
i really wanted to prove to the people
in our community
that we meant it that like it was coming
from a place of love
a place of humility you know i'm not
afraid to clean out where the trash can
is and like
redo the bathroom redo the bathrooms and
get on my hands and knees and
kind of make a big dirty dork of myself
if it means that you'll trust me the
story of samuels is one of many
burton shares in her memoir the rural
diaries
published in the midst of the pandemic
she asked her fans buying the book to
purchase
signed copies from her local bookstore
oblong
co-owner susannah herman says they sold
more than 7 thousand
copies we received a ppp
which was spectacular but we were closed
to the public for four months
so two months was ppp and two months
was hillary's book kept us paying our
staff
she's been our fairy godmother truly for
burton it was
just another way to support a community
where she
was able to find herself i found
so much self-worth in this community
that i hadn't in work
and when i'd accomplished everything i
said i was going to accomplish at a
young age
and still didn't really like myself
there was a problem first of all
you don't know me something she also
tackles in the book
including alleged abuse during her
acting career by one tree hill
showrunner mark schwann
why open yourself up like that in this
book i'm in a position
having walked away from hollywood having
walked away from the business in a way
where the repercussions for me are not
the same as they are for other people
but we put out a letter as the women of
one tree hill that was very polite
and it largely got ignored once we
started talking about the details of
that harassment
and abuse and trauma then people started
paying attention
but we still have yet to receive an
apology and acknowledgement from
any person involved in that production
another trauma burton writes openly
about
is the series of miscarriages before the
birth of her daughter
george it blindsided me i'd already had
a kid
you know and secondary infertility was
not something i had
any notion of um so i was in a bad
place and really looking to put my
energy into something so i would stop
thinking about myself
that something was a volunteer effort to
renovate a residential treatment center
for kids
the astor home for children we've been
spending more and more time with the
kids throughout the
the renovations and our fundraisers we
spent christmas eve with them this last
year
if you're going to put your time and
energy into something that's it
during the pandemic the morgans have
been putting their energy
into timely discussions on their new amc
series what films books or documentaries
can you recommend
it was supposed to be don't worry about
going out on friday nights
stay home with us let's all be safe
together
and then when george floyd
died not addressing that was
irresponsible
so we brought on guests who could speak
to it better than we could
we started having conversations about
representation
in our business once again walking the
walk
using her celebrity to foster change on
screen
and in her own community we are starting
to work with a new organization called
rhinebeck response
so many of the businesses in this town
are on the verge of collapse
because they didn't get the assistance
they don't have a fancy accountant to
muscle through the paperwork
so reinvent responds they're giving
loans they're giving grants and so we're
trying to fundraise with them
to keep as many businesses in town
afloat as possible
keep the town the way it is you got to
do the work
yeah yeah nothing comes easy
thankfully we live in an area that
really values this
and so even if reinbeck can be a model
for other towns you know
a road map i would love to see every
small town like this rehabilitated
and obviously i could not go there
without bringing sweets back
for all my look these are chocolate
covered espresso beans
chocolate covered espresso beans you
have what is this roasted salted
bourbon pecans caramels caramel yeah
everything is delicious and when you
read the book she talks so much about
the candy i literally was grabbing
things
that i'm like wait she wrote about that
and she loves that here i love
it's a really interesting read and the
message about rehabilitating a town and
working together
that's really so much a part of it and
what they're doing now especially with
this rhinebeck response group as well
as fish are you jealous are you jealous
you know where's mine i didn't get my
put some in your office i promise you
can just chuck it does it come together
i love
her and i really love her husband being
so supportive denny duque
from the race anatomy love it love